[Music]
BRIC the anchorman 2 Super ticket please
brick that was a beach ball there we go
oh so it is ah yes the anchorman 2 super
ticket brought to you by Fandango
magnificent isn't it
of course mine is much bigger than yours
will ever be it's the only way you will
see my movie first listen to this
smorgasbord of goodies you'll get take
it away Jack the anchorman two super
ticket premiere includes a ticket to see
anchorman two two days early on Monday
December 16th exclusively at AMC
Theaters get wake up Ron Burgundy
instantly an alternate full-length
version of the original anchorman film
yet anchorman 2 we in digital HD weeks
before DVD and blu-ray boy that's quite
a formidable package Jack and let me
throw in the old RB special yours truly
will personally come to your house and
make sweet love to your slightly
overweight but still firm white well
that's unfortunate for all parties
involved
I'm sorry America I will not be making
sweet love to your wife but you'll get
all that other anchorman stuff I will
still make love to your wife but not as
part of this promotional package it will
be a personal gift from me Ron Burgundy
and clearly not endorsed by anybody here
so to get your anchorman two super
ticket just click on the Fandango button
right there on the screen
go ahead America make Ron Burgundy proud
[Music]